standing as the penultimate boss of
eldon ring is a surprisingly enigmatic
figure given how much influence he has
had over the lands between and how much
he himself has gotten around the
continent his story is a vital one to
understanding the world and especially
to make sense of its in-game ending plus
unlike the other final boss he is not an
amorphous blob who has never actually
interacted with other characters in the
game so in this video i'm going to
explore the lore and life of none other
than the hero with a head of flaming red
hair radagon of the golden order
ratagon is an immediately interesting
figure after all we meet him at the very
ending of the game to find him as the
vessel of the elden ring somehow housed
in the same being as queen america the
purported god of the land we do have a
chance to see that ratagon is america
earlier in game but exactly what that
means or at least implies may be hard to
tell one thing we can say is that
radagon was likely not always part of
america he seems to once have been his
own distinct person we hear melano speak
about this in america's chambers
reciting words once said by merika
herself to ratagan
in america's own words
o radican
lil hound of the golden order
that yet to become me
thou art yet to become a god
let us be shattered
both
mine other self this was said sometime
before america and ratagon became one so
if raudogan began as his own person who
was he well in familiar from soft
fashion we are not given a backstory in
4k but we do have some clues to piece it
together
the most obvious of which is ratagon's
distinctive red hair his hair is
mentioned many times by item
descriptions and npc dialogue and nearly
all of his children inherited the hair
color with mikola being the only seeming
exception melania reichard radon and
even ronnie judging from some bits on
her original corpse have his red hair
reichard and radon's soldiers even
sported red apparel symbolizing their
lord's pedigrees as lord ratagan's sons
it's a prominent theme and this is
important because the only other havers
of red hair in the game are the fire
giants enemies of the order that were
all but wiped out the connection is made
clear in the giant's red braid which
states that every giant is rude of hair
and radagon is said to have despised his
own red locks perhaps that was a curse
of their kind this text is slightly
ambiguous the language about the curse
even in the original japanese does not
make it clear what exactly is being
referred to whether the curse is one on
the giants or the giants are cursing
ratagon or ratagon is being affected by
a curse laid to the giants we can't say
for certain past a connection being made
but it seems that the most likely
reading to me is that radagon himself
was a giant or at least part giant yes
he is not as tall as the final fire
giant but the trolls are giants too so
we know they can range in size and we
can see further confirmation of this
from the sword of milos which reads a
sinister greatsword fashioned from a
giant's backbone the spines along each
side of the blade have been tapered to a
fine point and meet out wounds like a
lopsided sawblade milos was undersized
for a giant and was viewed as sullied
and terribly grotesque
so if ratagan was a small giant he was
perhaps ostracized and considered
grotesque by the rest of his kind
these descriptions plus ratagan's son
radon being so massive in stature plus
ratagan having stony skin somewhat like
that of the fire giant and maybe radon
and reichard having similar eyes to the
fire giant all makes me lean towards
radagon being a giant or part giant
there seems to be a lot of evidence
pointing to this in any case this
relation with the giants to whatever
degree paints an interesting picture for
ratagon considering that the giants were
enemies of the order merica waged war on
them but ratagon is an extreme adherent
of the order merica called him lil hound
of the golden order leo meaning
dedicated or true hound clearly stating
devotion and subservience we can see why
ratagan as a devout order follower would
despise his connection with the giants
maybe he was originally prompted to the
golden order by the other giants
ostracizing him with some understanding
of his origins we can now move on to the
rest of his story pope turtle muriel
gives a good outline
lord radigan was a great champion
possessed of flowing red locks
he came to these lands at the head of a
great golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle
we can read from the sword's monuments
about these battles ratagon came at the
head of an army of the urge tree and
order during the first leonian war
ratagon's glory burned red as his hair
and we learn from the barrier of gold
incantation that this was when the
red-haired ratagon joined the hero's
ranks
but the warring was not successful we
read that during the second lyrinean war
no victory for the golden nor for the
moon no prize but atonement the birth of
a vow
muriel explains the stalemate and its
resolve radican once cleansed himself
with celestial dew
repented his territorial aggressions
and swore his love to rinala the order
of the urgery and the fate of the moon
were conjoined
and all the wounds of war forgiven
despite the strength of the golden order
and the greatness of radon's glory the
ernia could not be subdued through war
so it was instead brought into the fold
through marriage ratagon married the
lunar queen ranala and began a life in
the west for this new life he brought a
golden sewing needle and golden
tailoring tools which were just some of
the tools radagon brought when he
married ranala and joined the carrion
line maybe ratagan wanted to impress his
new wife with some wicked tailoring
skills which apparently go to waste on
his own clothing style of being forever
shirtless the further lower implications
of ratagon being a seamster are unknown
at this time but these tools do have
some relevance to the story after all we
see that ratagon had carrying magic
preceptors don masks with mouths sewn
shut with gold thread to make it clear
that all of their matters were to be
kept strictly private the gold thread
was likely from his tailoring kit and a
keen eye will note the pattern of the
thread a crisscross grid that we will
later see to be the symbol of radagon
and the shape of his rune part of the
elden ring itself
i had found this item description but
didn't notice that the gold thread was
in its shape until bhati's video and he
credited quail egg with the discovery so
quite the chain of lore telephone now
that i'm telling all of you about it but
before we get to the rune we have a bit
more backstory including the fact that
ratagan's sewing tools were not the only
wedding gift or tool in the snowy norths
you may come across a misbegotten
crusader bearing the golden order
greatsword a weapon of light that king
consort radagon forged to proudly
symbolize the tenets of the golden order
from the title of king consort we know
that this sword was forged after
ratagan's marriage with ranala but the
rest of the description reveals a secret
it says telltale signs betray that this
was once the great sword bequeathed to
ratagon by his first wife rinala
this sword was originally ranala's
wedding gift to ratagan as part of a
carion tradition we learn about this
tradition from the darkmoon greatsword
which we find at the end of ronnie's
questline
it reads a moon great sword bestowed by
a carrying queen upon her spouse to
honor long-standing tradition just as by
becoming ronnie's consort we receive the
darkmoon greatsword ratagon received the
original form of the golden order
greatsword from his marriage with ranala
and then he reforged it to be all about
the golden order we can see that ratagan
did not want to dwell on his ex very
unlike his ex so ratagan and ranala got
married and there was peace in the west
they had three children radon riker and
ronnie who as i said inherited their
father's locks
but unlike the possibly shameful
connection to the giants the hare had
for radagon to his children the red hair
had heroic implications we see that
radon inherited the furious flaming red
hair of his father ratagon and was fond
of its heroic implications saying i was
born a champion's cub now i am the lord
of the battlefields lion ratagon's
heroics and feats as a champion gave the
red hair a connotation of might and
pride during this time ratagon also
studied sorcery a fitting practice for
the husband of vernala of caria and
fitting 2 since he probably did not have
much sorcery experience during his time
in the golden order but with him being
focused more on incantations we don't
receive much more information about
ratagan's time in lyria for he would
soon abandon ranala and return to lane
dell and the head of the golden order
muriel once again gives us the 4-1-1
when godfrey first elden lord was
hounded from the lands between
radigan left rinala to return to the
earth tree capital
becoming queen america's second husband
and king consort
taking the title of second elden lord
the mystery endures to this day
as to why lord radigan would cast lady
ranala aside
and moreover
why a mere champion would be chosen for
the seat of eldon lord
when ronald lost her husband ratagan her
heart went along with him
ratagon left leonia and ranala became a
husk of her former self this is likely
why she seemed so hollow when we find
her after her boss fight she could not
even truly fight us ronnie had to cast a
spell which included a past version of
ranala to fight in her place
but ratagan did leave ronaldo with a
gift the amber egg that she clutches and
within it resides the great rune of the
unborn a final memento that ronaldo
clutches onto with the last of her being
the last aspect of ratagon in her life
well that and the dog
then ratagan went to queen america and
became the second elden lord in a
mysterious move that muriel doesn't
understand fortunately for us we do not
have four broken legs and we can leave
the church of vows to go find out the
secret that explains this monumental
happening is found by following the
clues of something else muriel said
about ratagan
you know it's said that lord radican
harbored a secret
a famed sculptor of the earth tree
capital was once summoned to render lord
ratikin's likeness in giant stature
when he glimpsed the skeleton in
raleigh's closet
and as such it's said the great statue
harbors his secret too
we can find the statue in lindell and
then perform the law of regression
incantation in front of it to solve two
mysteries at once the statue transforms
into america and gives a message ratagon
is merica
we already mentioned this before but in
gameplay this is the moment when it is
revealed that king consort ratagon and
god queen america are one in the same
we know from earlier that ratagon and
america were not always the same so this
provides the answer to muriel's
confusion ratagon left for nala and was
able to become the second elden lord
despite being a mere champion because he
was chosen to become one and fuse with
america we will see more evidence later
but i think ratagon was chosen by the
golden order or the greater will itself
to fuse with america as a kind of
insurance policy ratagon was a golden
order fanatic and america seems to have
been turning away from the order radagon
could have been brought in to keep
america in line which we will see happen
later when ratagan joined america his
children with ranala became demi god's
stepchildren after the union he also
went on to have two more children
through some odd practice of self-cess
with himself his other self america out
of this peculiar arrangement came nicola
and melania melania inherited her
father's red hair and mykola his
mother's golden hair
i had said ratagon practiced sorceries
in lyria after the move he practiced
incantations upon becoming america's
husband his icon notes that through this
dual practice did the hero aspire to be
complete this phrasing plays into the
theme of ratagon as incomplete or as
just part of a whole which we see on
display given his relationship to
america ratagaon was also able to blend
this incantation practice into some
solid father-son time in what is one of
the only known examples in the whole
game of a father actually doing stuff
with their kid ratagan seems to have
taught mikala about incantations since
we know that mikala being the fearsome
empyrean prodigy that he is developed at
least two incantations the discus of
light and the triple rings of light as
gifts to his father and in see mean
response ratagon created radagon's rings
of light hopefully he had a less
egotistical nickname for it as a gift of
gratitude to the young michela of note
is the fact that all of these
incantations are golden order
fundamentalisms which once again
highlights ratagan's love for the golden
order plus this last incantation is
found in the golden order principia
which also contains the law of
regression one of the two key
fundamentals of the golden order and
what we used to reveal the ratagon
statue yet this golden order fanaticism
did not rub off on mikala the rest of
the description of ratagan's rings of
light tells the tale
it reads and yet the young mykola
abandoned fundamentalism for it could do
nothing to treat melania's accursed rot
this was the beginning of unalloyed gold
mykolo would go on to create an
unalloyed gold needle to ward away the
meddling of outer gods and attempt to
cure his sister of her rot curse the
golden order and the greater will could
not or chose not to save his sister so
mykola abandoned them and all other
outer gods attempting to do it himself
and his use of a gold needle makes me
think of ratagon's gold sewing needle
and his other tailoring tools perhaps
mikola found these tools and used them
as the basis for his needle it would be
an ironic twist of fate for the
fanatic's son to use his own tools as
the means of walking down a completely
opposite path
and i believe that covers the history of
radagon every chiefly notable event that
we know about him before the events of
the game if i miss something let me know
in the comments
in game we find ratagon trapped in the
erd tree or maybe we should say america
is the one trapped since it seems to be
ratagon's rune on the outside of the
urgery with the thorns not letting us
pass the same symbol that we saw on the
mouths of the carion preceptors
we find confirmation of this rune as
ratagans in his scar seal which bears
the same rune and reads an eye engraved
with an elden rune said to be the seal
of king consort ratagon these seals
represent the lifelong duty of those
chosen by the gods
there's also his sore seal which
features the rune sinking into the eye
even deeper it adds another layer of
description saying solemn duty weighs
upon the one beholden not unlike a
gnawing curse from which there is no
deliverance a gnawing curse is an apt
description for how the rune seems to be
sinking into the eye
these seals seem to be describing how
ratagon was chosen for a certain duty
and chosen in such a way that he likely
had no choice in the matter like
annoying curse
fittingly merica has a similar set of
seals which say the same
if ratagan and america are being forced
to act by the greater will it makes
sense why america would try to break
free and it serves as a testament to his
faith that ratagon would still follow
the order's path viewing his assigned
duty as righteous despite his own lack
of say in the matter
so ratagan sealed the erd tree sometime
after the shattering which i should
point out he also tried to stop merica's
hammer tells us how the night went down
a stone hammer made in the lands of the
newman outside the lands between the
tool with which queen merica shattered
the elden ring and radagon attempted to
repair it the hammer partially broke
upon shattering the ring becoming
splintered with rune fragments
radagon tried to repair the elden ring
but he could not so he sealed off the
erd tree and trapped himself and merica
inside along with crucifying marika and
sticking a spear in her side to really
fit the christ-like symbolism
once we burn the urge tree and unseal
destined death the entry to the
fractured stone is opened we can step in
and finally see the red-haired hero in
his stony broken flesh
inside his shattered body we see the
elden ring including his rune of
crisscross gold ratagon fights with the
zeal of a golden order fanatic filled
with a variety of golden incantations
and hammer strikes sporting his
distinctive weapon art goldbreaker which
is called the heroic ratagon's signature
attack
he even features attacks with his own
rune and one that seems to make the
outline of the elden ring on the ground
upon his defeat ratagan falls and his
body becomes the weapon of the elden
beast whose sacred relic sword reads a
sword wrought from the remains of a god
who should have lived a life eternal
thoughts on what the weapon portends are
many and buried some consider it the
mark of a great sin or a sign of great
devastation some think of it as the end
of an age while others the beginning
ratagon seemed to always be a tool for
the greater will to enact its designs in
the lands between perhaps it took
advantage of the hatred he had for his
giant affiliation to push him down its
path or perhaps things were the other
way around and ratagon disliked his
giant side simply because he was a
golden order fundamentalist either way
it made him a perfect candidate and
vessel for the elden ring at least as it
was under the influence of the greater
will
looking at him in this way ratagan's end
of becoming a tool of the greater will
in another way this time as a sword for
its beast is thematically fitting in
life and in death ratagon is a tool of
this outer god being sent on each and
every mission it had for him he seems to
have been able to find some loved ones
along the way but his life's overriding
purpose was always that as an arm of the
order a purpose that stretched even
beyond his final breaths he becomes the
sword that is the elden beast's weapon
in the last fight of eldon ring however
the elden beast boss fight is utter
trash and that unfortunately makes me
feel sad to have a grand character and
final boss fight like ratagon being
co-opted by the lesser amorphous blob
run around for 10 minutes boss fight i
don't have any more of a thematic way to
end this video so i will conclude by
saying that radagon is cool even with
his religious zealotry and that i'm not
actually done with the video i have a
couple more points about ratagon that i
couldn't fit into the script naturally
so i'm just going to bring them up now
first is a note about something we can
find in ferum azula what looks like a
design of an old elden ring maybe what
it looked like during the age of the
dragons of note is the lack of ratagan's
rune however the tree roots overlapping
the ring look like they could be an old
version of the rune with similar but
more natural criss-crossing maybe
radigan's rune came into being when he
fused with america and the elden ring
took on a new design
another thing is that the sealed gates
in rio lucaria seem to have a design
similar to radagon's rune
that's about all i have on that one they
just look similar
and lastly is a note about viewing
ratagon and america as the revies others
like xeostorm and people on the elden
ring subreddit have identified quite a
number of alchemical references in eldon
rings world chief among them is the
rebbies the end product of alchemy it's
magnum opus or great work the rebbies
comes from the latin res bina which
means dual or double matter it is a
fusing of opposite halves into one being
notably a male half corresponding to the
sun and a female half corresponding to
the moon it has heavy association with
another concept called the red king and
white queen which i believe is another
way of saying the philosopher's stone
though i could be wrong on that from
hair color to hermaphroditic fusing
there are a lot of parallels to eldon
ring and ratagon and america this could
be important to understanding ratagon
but it could also be from soft
referencing some real world symbolism
without putting much explicit detail
about it in the characters which is kind
of what the christ-like connections seem
to be to me
america being in a crucifixion position
especially with the spear in her side
and horolu being in the same position in
the opening i think there's an element
of meaning here like them being
sacrificial and to some degree feeling a
christ-like role in the game but it's
also not something that at least in
those two examples i would take too far
i wouldn't think the spear america side
has some specific strong meaning but
maybe there is something deeper into
both of those and there's in-game
evidence to justify such a deeper
reading of it all this kind of reasoning
does seem like a cool path of
exploration and as a lore head of eldon
ring and dark souls i'm not one to
really curtail somebody exploring really
deep and at times stupidly niche levels
of investigation but this video is
already long enough so i'll keep things
more centered on the game's explicit
references to ratagon and his life story
alright my audio recording is looking at
over 40 minutes so without much more to
conclude i hope you have enjoyed
watching subscribe for more elden ring
lore and comment your thoughts about
ratagan and his story you can also
comment any other lore you are looking
forward to me covering i'll be making a
good amount of it i'll be making more of
these videos so be sure to stick around
this has been mad luigi thanks for
watching bye